we've already looked at faraday's law in
some detail it showed us that if we have
some
some loop of conductor and we have we
have a change in magnetic flux over time
through the surface defined by that loop
it's going to induce an emf through that
loop which will cause a current to start
to to circulate through that loop and
that current of course will be dependent
on the actual resistance of the
conductor and there's many ways that
we've already seen of having a change in
magnetic flux one you could have a
change in the magnetic field you could
it could be a change in its magnitude
and or its orientation you can have a
change in the shape of the actual loop
of conductor if its area increases or
decreases that will change the flux
remember the flux is just your the
component of the magnetic field that is
that is perpendicular to the surface if
you take the average of that times the
area of the surface and then the other
way that we're going to study in this
video
is inducing an electromag an
electromotive force by changing it not
the shape of the loop and not the
magnetic field but by changing the
orientation of the loop and in
particular we're going to have the loop
rotate
so let's think about this so i have this
loop here it's connected to this axle
and i'm going to rotate it in a i'm
going to rotate it in a clockwise
direction through this constant magnetic
field you can see it's constant of the
magnetic field vectors i've just sampled
them at different points in the field
they're all pointing straight up and
i've drawn them so that they all have
the same magnitude now what we need to
appreciate is as we rotate this the
angle between the magnetic field and the
surface is changing and right from this
point as we rotate in this clockwise
direction the component of the magnetic
field that is perpendicular to the
surface is going to increase now what am
i talking about well let's look at it
from this point of view let's look at it
from the point of view of the actual
loop of wire so from this point of view
the magnetic field is at some angle i
could draw that angle here so you know
whatever angle it's a little hard to see
whatever angle this is we could say that
is that angle here and as we rotate the
entire loop it's attached to some type
of an axle here in a clockwise direction
what is going to happen to this angle
well after let's say delta t let's say
we're just rotating it at a at a
constant rate
we're going to have
the magnetic
so after we've rotated a little bit
the the magnetic field vector is going
to look something like that
so it's the component that is
perpendicular to the surface is what we
care about for flux it's going to go
from being like this
it's going to go from being like that to
going
to being
to being like this
to being like this so at least for this
point of the rotation for this point of
rotation until we get to the flat until
we get to the flat point until we have
our until we have our loop being
completely flat the purple the
the component of our magnetic field that
is perpendicular is going to increase
which is going to have so we're going to
have an increase in flux over that time
so if we have an increase in flux over
that time as we rotate up at least until
we get to the flat point what is going
to happen well we're going to induce a
current and then we just have to think
about what is the orientation of the
current so we want to have a current
that will induce a magnetic field that
will go against the change in flux so
the current should induce a magnetic
field that is if our flux at least for
that part of the rotation is is
increasing in the upwards direction if
we're from the point of view of of this
loop then we need to create a magnetic
field
that is acting against that so a
magnetic field that is acting against
that or we need to create we're going to
induce a current that induces a magnetic
field that acts against that change in
flux
so how do i what type of a current would
induce a magnetic field like that so
i'll just use the right hand rule my
fingers would go in the direction of
these of the of the magnetic field so my
fingers
and i have to use my right hand so my
fingers are going to go in that
direction so my right hand my thumb
my thumb would go
in this direction
so that is going to be the direction of
the current that is induced so the whole
point of me showing you this is that
there's multiple ways to have a change
in magnetic flux and there's multiple
ways to induce a current and this one is
particularly interesting because it lets
you and or we can start to think about
wow i could turn i could turn a
mechanical rotation into an induced
current and this is this basic principle
although they wouldn't use such a simple
loop like this is exactly how electric
generators work they're actually in some
ways the reverse of an electric motor an
electric motor has a current that causes
something to rotate here we're having
something rotate causing a current to
form and that's actually what we have
happening when you look at something
like windmills or when you look at
hydroelectric generators right over here
this windmill the wind is going to cause
these blades to turn around and then
inside inside of this little place right
over here
you're going to have a more fancy
version of this rotating which is going
to induce a current and the magnetic
field isn't going to be exactly like
this and it's going to be a more
sophisticated mechanism but it's the
same underlying principle it's just
faraday's lot work same thing with
hydroelectric generator you're using the
potential energy of the of the flowing
water to turn an axle and then that
helps us generate electricity by the
exact same principle